لعنه وعليكم الى يوم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مساء الخير للجميع اليوم الشرطه السويديه
سحبت الحمايه عني اليوم الشرطه السويديه
سحبت المكان اللي كنت انا اسكن فيه المكان
المحمي الشرطه السويديه خلتني فريسه سهله
للمسلمين اليوم
باي شيء الا القران وان فعلت فستجد نفسك
امام حشود غاضبه لن تهدا ولن تبرد صدورها
الا باخذ حقها في السويد تجرا شاب عراقي
واحرق المصحف باسم حريه التعبير قائلا
للمسلمين ها انا باحرق كتابكم المقدس فهل
تستطيعون فعل شيء العالم الاسلامي ينتفض
ويقول
اوقفوا هذه المهزله وهذا الشاب لابد ان
يقدم للمحاكمه السويد ترد انها حريه
التعبير عن الراي لن نحاكمه ونفس الشخص
وباختلاف التوقيت يقوم مره اخرى
المسلمون يزدادون غضبا ومشاعرهم الدينيه
تعتصر الما خصوصا العراق لان هذا العراقي
ابن جلدته
وخذي اثاثك فلا مكان لك بيننا بينما في
الطرف الاخر الاف العراقيين يقتحمون
السفاره السويديه ويضرمون النيران فيها
احفاد الفايكنج يتراجعون ويصدمون الشاب
العراقي قائلين له عذرا لقد خرج الوضع عن
السيطره ونحن لن نستطيع حمايتك بعد الان
عليك ان تواجه مصيرك وحدك يظهر الشاب في
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي يرتعد خوفا ويقول
تركوني فريسه سهله للمسلمين لا ادري ماذا
افعل الان ما هي الصفعه التي وجهها العراق
للسويد ردا على حرق القران وما هو التهديد
الذي وجهه احفاد الفايكنج للشاب العراقي
وجعله يبكي دما على فعلته وماذا قال الشاب
مستندا بالجميع بعد موقف السويد الجديد
منه
زئير اسود الرافدين
شارون كاملون لم يكن كافيا بتهدئه
المسلمين عموما والعراق خصوصا فلا يزال
الغليان يسري في صدور العالم الاسلامي منذ
ان قام الشاب العراقي سلوى المقيم في
السويد بحرق المصحف الشريف في يونيو
الماضي ليقوم نفس الشخص باستفزاز المسلمين
مره اخرى ويدهس المصحف بقدميه ويحرق علم
العراق امام السفاره العراقيه
ولكن وكما يقول المثل مش كل مره تسلم
الجره لقد فاجات الحكومه العراقيه السويد
باغلاق سفرتها في بغداد وطرد السفيره
السويديه بل واستدعاء القائم بالاعمال
العراقي من ستوكهولم ما يعني قطع العلاقات
رسميا وانهاء اي تعاون مشترك بين البلدين
لتوجه بغداد رساله صريحه الى ستوكهولم
تقول فيها لقد سئمنا من حريه التعبير
المزعومه التي استخدم ضد الاسلام وبلادنا
فقط لا علاقه بين الاما دمتم مصرين على
حمايه هذا الشاب ولم يكتفي ابناء الرافدين
بهذا الموقف بل قاموا باقتحام سفاره
السويد في بغداد وادرام النيران فيها في
رساله واضحه منهم يقولون فيها لن اصمت على
اي اهانه ويمكننا فعل اي شيء دفاعا عن
مشاعرنا الدينيه فبماذا ردت السويد
السويد تقدم قربانا للمسلمين على عكس
المتوقع تراجع احفاد الفايكنج امام قطار
بغداد الغاضب وقاموا بتوجيه رساله للشاب
العراقي سلوى قائلين لا تعتمد على حمايهنا
بعد الان فلن نخسر حلفائنا ومصالحنا من
اجل عيونك سلوان يشعر بالخطر لاول مره فقد
رفع عنه غطاء الحمايه وترك وحيدا ليكون
لقمه سائغه في افواه اسود بغداد
يبدو ان رساله ستوكول له كان شديده اللهجه
حتى انه خرج في فيديو قائلا اليوم قامت
الشرطه السويديه برفع الحميه عني وقامت
بسحب المكان الذي اسكن فيه لقد جعلتني
فريسه سهله للمسلمين واخبرتني نصا انني
يجب ان نتوقف عن انتقاد المسلمين والتباور
ووصلت لدرجه انهم هددوني باعاده فتح ملف
لجوء واعاده للعراق واضافه انا اتعرض
لضغوطات كثيره من الممكن ان يتم قتلي في
اي لحظه انا الان في مكان غير محمي وحياتي
في خطر ماذا بك يا سلوان لماذا ترتعد
فرائسك الان الست انت من اهان المصحف
الشريف بكل جراه وتحديت المسلمين كالاسد
ما دمت لست بشجاعه الكافيه للمواجهه
فلماذا ارتديت جلد الاسود اذا من البدايه
هكذا يكون الشعب العراقي نعم سلوان اصبح
في مازق كبير وكان لسان حاله يقول كنت
احتمي بعباءه حريه الغرب وطننت انهم
سيحمونني لم اكن اعلم انهم سيتركونني
اواجه مصيري وحدي معذره يا سلوان فقد سبق
السيف العدل ولم تعد امامك فرصه حتى للندم
ويبدو ان هذه المره لن تمر مرور الكرام
فموقف العراق واضح وان لم تخضع استوكهولم
باوامر بغداد اليوم ربما تحظو دول اسلاميه
اخرى حفظ العراق وستكون خساره السويد اثقل
مما تستطيع التحمله وانتم مشاهدينا هل
ترون ان موقف العراق كاف لوضع الامور في
نصابها الصحيح وهل ستقوم السويد بتسليم
سلوان للحكومه العراقيه لمحاكمته ام ان
الامور ستهدا بمجرد توقفه عن انتقاد
الاسلام والمسلمين اخبرونا في صندوق
التعليقات
[موسيقى]